ASSEMBLY
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING WE HAVE FIVE
MINUTES LEFT OF THE MORNING. DO
TO A GROUP OF ONGOING COVERT
PRECAUTIONS MASKER REQUIRED FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS IN THE HEARING
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL. YOU CAN
TESTIFY IN PERSON BY TELEPHONE
OR REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
OUTDOORS ON THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL. THE NUMBER TO CALL
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. THIS
NUMBER CAN BE FOUND ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND IS
DISPLAYED ON YOUR SCREENS. FOR
THOSE CALLING IN PLEASE MAKE
YOURSELVES WELL IN THE QUEUE TO
ELIMINATE BACKGROUND NOISE. FOR
WITNESSES CALLING IN YOU WILL
BE PLACED IN A QUEUE UNTIL YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. WHEN IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND THEN
MUTE YOURSELVES IN ORDER TO
SPEAK. AND THEN PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
WITH THAT. WE'LL BEGIN. I AM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JIM FRAZIER
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO WELCOME YOU TO
THIS MORNING'S INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. THE TRIBAL STATE
GAMING COMPACT BEFORE US TODAY
WE EXECUTED A SKINNER WERE
EXECUTED THIS YEAR BETWEEN
GOVERNU SOME. ON BEHALF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA OF POMO
INDIANS OF CALIFORNIA. SANTA
ROSA INDIAN COMMUNITY OF THE
SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA ALSO KNOWN
AS- TOUCHY YOU'LL CUT DRIVE.
AND PICKER YUN RANCHERIA OF
TRUTH TO CHANCY INDIANS OF
CALIFORNIA. TODAY WE WILL HEAR
FROM THE PRINCIPAL ARCHITECTS
OF THE OF THE COMPACTS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE CHAIR
OF EACH TRIBE. EACH COMPACT
AUTHORIZES A TRIBE TO OPERATE A
MAXIMUM NUMBER OF GAMING
DEVICES AS DESIGNATED NUMBER OF
GAMING FACILITIES LOCATED ON
ELIGIBLE INDIAN LANDS HELD IN
TRUST FOR THE TRIBE. AND
LOCATED WITHIN THE BOUNDARIES
OF THE TRIBE'S RESERVATION.
UNDER EACH COMPACT THE TRIBE
HAS AGREED TO PAY THE STATE IS
PRO RATA SHARE OF COST THE
STATE INCURS FOR THE POOR
PERFORMANCE OF ITS DUTIES UNDER
THE COMPACT. THE CONTACTS
INCLUDE PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW
FOR OFF RESERVATION MITIGATION
AND ESTABLISHES A PROCESS FOR
DISPUTE WERE TO ARISE. I AM
PLEASED TO SEE THAT THESE
COMPACT MIRROR MANY OF THE
RECENT CONTACTS THAT HAVE COME
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
AREA OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS. MEANINGFUL
CONSUMER EMPLOYEE PROTECTIONS
LABOR PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW YOU
WORKERS TO UNIONIZE UNDER
SPECIFIED CONDITIONS. ONCE
AFFECTED THESE CONTACTS WILL BE
IN FULL FORCE AND EFFECTIVE FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS FOLLOWING
THAT THEY. I JUST WANT TO
REMIND ALL INTERESTED PARTIES
THAT NO FORMAL VOTE WILL BE
TAKEN TODAY TODAY'S HEARING IS
FOR THIS COMMITTEE TO BE
BRIEFED ON THE CONTENT OF EACH
CONTACT. AS THEY CANNOT BE
AMENDED BY THE LEGISLATURE. SB
THREE OH TWO BY CENTERED ON GOD
IS THE RATIFICATION BILL FOR
PICAYUNE. RANCHERIA OF CHASSIS
INDIANS COMPACT. AB NINE FIFTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
IS THE RATIFICATION BILL FOR
THE- MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA POMO
INDIANS AND THE TOUCHY YOU
COULD. TRY PET CONTACTS. AT
SOME POINT NEXT WEEK BOTH WILL
BE TAKEN UP FOR CONSIDERATION
BY THE ENTIRE BODY. ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK OUR WITNESSES IN ADVANCE
FOR TAKING TIME OUT OF YOUR
BUSY SCHEDULE TO BE WITH US
TODAY. SO WITHOUT FURTHER ADO
LET'S BEGIN THIS HEARING. THE
FIRST COMPACT IT WILL BE
BRIEFED ON WILL BE THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA OF POMO
INDIANS OF CALIFORNIA. NATHAN
VOEPEL USE AND TERM TROUBLE
NEGOTIATIONS ADVISER FOR
GOVERNOR NEWSOM WELL FIRST
PERSON PRESENT FIRST. AND I
UNDERSTAND MR DISSIPATING
REMOTELY MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR MISTER WILL GUILTY
SO WE CAN BEGIN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS NATALIE AND I'M FILLING IN
FOR ANNA NAY MARKETS ENTERING
TRIBAL NEGOTIATIONS ADVISER FOR
THE GOVERNOR. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO OVER THE
TRIBAL STATE GAMING COMPACT FOR
THE MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA LATER
THE CONTACTS FOR SANTA ROSA
INDIAN COMMUNITY OF THE SANTA
ROSA RANCHERIA AND- TAKING ALL
THREE HAVE CHECKED CHAMPIONS. I
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE TRIBES
CHAIRPERSONS CHAIR SIMON JUST
AS CO INSURED GONZALEZ THESE
CONTACTS COULD NOT HAVE BEEN
FINALIZED. WITHOUT THEIR
ENGAGEMENT SUPPORT. HOW CAN
WITH A BRIEF. TO THE TRAVELS
COMPACT AND CROSS IN THE OVER
THE FOR THE- THAT. CAN IN ALL
THREE COM BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY WELL KNOWN AS I GO TO.
THROUGH THIS THIS TERMS
SPECIFIC TO MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA AND LATER CAN DO THE
SAME FOR SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA
AND PICKY AND RANCHERIA.
CALIFORNIA VOTERS IN PROP ONE
A. APPROVED AMENDING THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION ARTICLE
FOUR SECTION NINETEEN TWELVE I
TRIED TO OPERATE SLOT MACHINES
TAKING A PERCENTAGE CARD GAMES
LOTTERY GAMES ON INDIAN LANDS.
THE FEDERAL INDIAN GAMING
REGULATORY ACT- IT GROW
AUTHORIZES THE TRIED TO OFFER
SLOT MACHINES ANOTHER CLASS
THREE GAMES. THAT ARE PERMITTED
IN THE STATE IF THE TRIBE IS
NEGOTIATED A CLASS THREE GAMING
COMPACT. EVER BROADLY LIMITS
CONTACTS TO SUBJECTS DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THE OPERATION GAMING
ACTIVITIES. IN ACCORDANCE WITH
A GRAND PROP ONE A. THE
GOVERNOR NEGOTIATED THESE
COMPACTS SUBJECT TO LEGISLATIVE
RATIFICATION. BUT THREE
CONTACTS CONTAIN THE ELEMENTS
TRADITIONALLY INCLUDED IN PRIOR
RATIFIED CONTACT THAT ARE
TAILORED FOR EACH TRIED. TO
CONTACT YOU TO RESPECTFUL
LANGUAGE CAREFULLY DEVELOPED BY
THE TRIBES IN THE STATE TO
REFLECT EXISTING TRAVEL CALL.
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOVERNMENT
TO GOVERNMENT NATURE OF THE
TRIBAL STATE RELATIONSHIPS. AS
YOU MENTIONED THE CONTRACTORS
ARE FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND
THEY INCLUDE FORCED MEASURE
LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS REDUCED
OPERATIONS ARE CLOSURES FROM
EPIDEMICS AND PANDEMICS WILD
FIRES AND OTHER EVENTS OUTSIDE
OF A TRYING TO CONTROL. THIS
LANGUAGE ALLOWS FOR POTENTIAL
WAIVER OR DEFERRAL OF PAYMENT
OBLIGATIONS DUE TO THESE
UNFORESEEN EVENTS. CONTACT ALSO
GRANT THE TRIBES THE RIGHT TO
TERMINATE OR NEGOTIATED AN
AMENDMENT IF THEY LOSE THEIR
EXCLUSIVE RIGHT TO OPERATE A
GAMING DEVICES UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION. THE
THREE CONTACTS INCLUDE ECONOMIC
TERMS REGARDING THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF CLASS THREE SLOT
MACHINES AND GAMING FACILITIES
THAT A TRIBESMAN OPERATE. ALL
THREE TRIBES COMMITTED TO A PRO
RATA SHARE OF PAYMENTS TO THE
SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION FUND- STF.
YES THE APP IS USED TO
REIMBURSE THE STATE FOR ITS
REGULATORY AND OTHER DIRECT
COSTS OF TRIBAL GAMING. THE
MIDDLETOWN OF ENTRY AFTER ITS
TWIN PINE CASINO IN LAKE COUNTY
CURRENTLY OPERATES JUST UNDER
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY GAMING
DEVICES. UNDER THIS NEW COMPACT
THE TRIBE CAN EXPAND UP TO
TWELVE HUNDRED GAMING DEVICES
ACROSS TO FACILITIES. IN
RECOGNITION OF ITS PRIOR
PREPAYMENT OF FEES FOR UNUSED
GAME LICENSES MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA COMPACT PROVIDES FOR
A CREDIT AGAINST ITS SDF
OBLIGATION. WHICH I WILL HAVE
NO PAYMENT OBLIGATIONS TO THE
REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUNDER
RSTS. IT CONTINUES TO OPERATE
LESS THAN THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
GAMING DEVICES AS A LIMITED
GAMING TRIED IT WILL REMAIN
CULTURAL FOR ONE POINT ONE
MILLION ANNUALLY. FROM THE RSTS.
THE COMPACTS INCLUDE STANDARD
CONTROLS TO ENSURE FAIR PLAY
HONESTY AND INTEGRITY AND
OPERATIONS. THESE INCLUDE
FACILITY EMPLOYEE RESOURCE
SUPPLIER AND FINANCIAL SOURCE
LICENSING STANDARDS. ANY DEVICE
TESTING AND INSPECTIONS AND
FEDERAL STATE AND TRIBAL GAMING
REGULATIONS. MINORS UNDER AGE
TWENTY ONE IN THE CASE OF
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA ARE
PROHIBITED FROM GAINING OR
PURCHASING TOBACCO PRODUCTS IN
THE FACILITIES ALL WILL INCLUDE
A NON SMOKING AREA. ALCOHOL
PURCHASED SALES AND SERVICE THE
TRIBE'S GAMING FACILITIES WILL
COMPLY WITH CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS. CONSISTENT WITH
OTHER RECENT CONTACTS THE
CONTACTS INCORPORATE RTHER
THAN DIRECT TRIBAL LAW THE
THREE TRIBES ELECTED TO
INCORPORATE INTO THE CONTACT
THEIR TRIBAL ORDINANCES FOR
PATRON DISPUTES TORTS AND
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION. ALL
OF WHICH CONTAIN APPROPRIATE
DUE PROCESS PROVISIONS.
ADDITIONALLY THE TRIED TO
CONNECT TO ENSURING MINIMUM
WAGE RATES AT LEAST AS
STRINGENT AS CALIFORNIANS AND
MAINTAINING A TRAVEL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCE THIRTEEN A
LARA. THE TLR OVER MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA IS THE SAME AS OTHERS
RECENTLY APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. IT TAKES EFFECT
WHEN I TRIED IN PLACE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY OR MORE PEOPLE
EXCLUDING TRAVEL MEMBERS
ENTERTAINING RELATED
FACILITIES. THE TELLER-%
FUNCTIONS AS A MECHANISM FOR A
BILATERAL CONTRACT BETWEEN THE
TRIED AND LABOR ORGANIZATION.
IF THE LABOR ORGANIZATION
ACCEPTS THE DEALER OF THE TRIBE
CONNECTS TO BINDING DISPUTE
RESOLUTION FOR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AND OTHER DISPUTES.
THE DRIVE ALSO AGREES NOT TO
STATE OPPOSITION TO A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT- PARTICULAR UNION
DURING THE NOTICE OF INTENT TO
ORGANIZE PERIOD. THE LABOR
ORGANIZATION FOR ITS PART
AGREES NOT TO STRIKE HER PICK
IT UP THE TRIBE'S CASINO. OR
ATTEMPT TO INFLUENCE AN
ELECTION. EITHER PARTY MAY GO
TO COURT TO COMPEL ARBITRATION
OR COMPLIANCE WITH AN
ARBITRATION AWARD. ALSO
CONSISTENT WITH PRIOR RECENT
CONTACTS. THESE CONTACTS IN
CORPORATE ROBUST ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW PROCEDURES FOR POTENTIAL
OPPOSITION IMPACTS. PARALLEL
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT REVIEW PROCESS
ALLOWING FOR CATEGORICAL
EXEMPTIONS A NEGATIVE
DECLARATION. I TRIED IS NOT
ABLE TO SUFFICIENTLY MITIGATE
OR AVOID IMPACTS THEN THE TRIBE
MUST COMPLETE A TRIBAL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT
INCOME TO AN INTER GOVERNMENTAL
AGREEMENT WITH THE LOCAL CITY
COUNTY OR CALTRANS IN CERTAIN
INSTANCES. IN THE CASE OF
IMPASSE EITHER THE TRIBE OR THE
LOCAL JURISDICTION MAY SEEK
ARBITRATION. THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA CONTACT INCLUDES AN
ALTERNATIVE PROCESS THAT THE
TRIAL WILL BE OPERATING NOMORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED FORTY NINE
GAMES. WIRES THE TRIED TO MEET
AND CONFER WITH THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION TO MITIGATE
IMPACTS TO PUBLIC SERVICES. IN
A BINDING COMMITMENT BY THE
TRACTOR PERFORMANCE MITIGATION
OBLIGATIONS. THIS PETER
GUARDING THE NEED OR SCOPE OF
MEDICATION ARE ADDRESSED
THROUGH ARBITRATION WITH THE
STATE. FINALLY CONTACT INCLUDED
DISPUTE RESOLUTION PROCESS TO
ADDRESSING THE ALLEGED BREACH
IN TWO AND FORCE CONTACT TERMS.
CONTACTS ARE STRUCTURED TO
ENCOURAGE GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS TO RESOLVE
DISAGREEMENTS RESPECTIVE OF THE
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT NATURE
OF A COMPACT. IF THE STAIN
TRIBES BEST EFFORTS TO
NEGOTIATE DON'T SUCCEED CONTACT
CALL FOR A MEET AND CONFER
PROCESS. IF THAT'S UNSUCCESSFUL
IN THE TRIED AND STATE MAY
VOLUNTARILY ARBITRATE THE
DISPUTE. HOWEVER IF EITHER OF
THE TRIBE OF THE STATE DOES NOT
AGREE ARBITRATION THE PARTY
ALLEGING A BREACH CAN FILE IN
FEDERAL COURT. SEEKING A
DECLARATION OF THAT BREACH
AFTER GETTING THE OTHER PARTY
THIRTY DAYS TO CARE. IF THE
AFTER THE FINAL FINAL COURT
ORDER THE BREACHING PARTY STILL
IS NOT CURED WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS. THEN THE NON BREACHING
PARTY CAN ASK THE COURT TO
ORDER TERMINATION AT THE TRIBAL
STATE COMPACT. I APPRECIATE YOU
ALLOWING ME TO GO OVER THIS
INFORMATION TODAY ALL REMAIN
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS UNTIL
LATER HIGHLIGHT PROVISIONS FOR
THE OTHER TWO COMPACTS THE
DIGITAL. LATER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER BAILEY AS- WELL GO
AHEAD AND DO QUESTIONS AT THE
END OF ALL THE PRESENTATIONS
AND IF YOU'RE ITS RELATIVE FUEL
CALL YEP OKAY. SO TO GET THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO- JOSE
SOME OF THE THIRD THE CHAIR OF
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA POMO
INDIANS OF CALIFORNIA. MISTER
SIMON YOUR BEFORE. GERMAN
FRAZIER HELLO WE JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU AND THE MEMBERS
REVENUE HEARING TODAY MY NAME
IS JOSE SIMON FROM THE CHILDREN
OF THE MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA
BAND OF POMO INDIANS. I'M HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE FIVE SEVEN WHICH RATIFIED
AMENDMENTS TO THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA TRIBE'S GAMING
COMPACT WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE WISH TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMAN FRAZIER WAS
WILLINGNESS TO HOLD THIS
HEARING TO HEAR ABOUT OUR
UPDATED COMPACT. I WANT TO TAKE
ALSO SETTLEMENT SALAS. WHERE'S
WILLINGNESS TO OFFER A COMPACT
RATIFICATION BILL AND MOVED TO
WORK FOR RATIFICATION FOR THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA. THE BILL
TERRITORY AMANDA POIGNANCY
CALIFORNIA IS LOCATED IN
ELECTRONIC CALIFORNIA. ONE
NORTHEAST OF SANTA ROSA. THE
TRIBE OPERATES THREE HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE GOVERNMENT GAMING
DEVICES FURTHER TROUBLE BURKE
TRAVELS. NINETEEN NINETY NINE
COMPACT. UNIVERSITY IS LOCATED
IN THE SOUTH IN OAKLAND COUNTY.
WE ARE CURRENTLY ONE OF THE
LARGEST EMPLOYERS IN OUR AREA
WE WERE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES AT THIS TIME. THAT WE
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TODAY. DRIVES
INVOLVED IN LOCAL COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS. IN THE ECONOMY
HERE LOCALLY IN SOUTH LAKE
COUNTY. WE HAVE MULTIPLE.
ASSOCIATIONS WITH THE LOCAL
COUNTY GOVERNMENT IN ALSO WORK
OUR SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
OFFER SCHOLARSHIPS DROP
TRAINING ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAMS HELP THE WORLD
PERSISTENCE SOCIAL SERVICES
DONATIONS COMMUNITY MAINTENANCE
AND DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS OUR
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. OVER THE BORDER
GUARD JUSTIN COMPACT THE TRIBE
HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED
BY CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
RESULTING FIRES INCLUDING THE-
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN VALLEY
FIRE WHICH WAS DEVASTATING TO
OUR LOCAL ECONOMY IN OUR COUNTY.
SUBSEQUENTLY UNDERWENT THIRTEEN
DISASTERS A LAKE COUNTY AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THE LAST SIX YEARS.
THE FIRE NEGATIVELY IMPACTED
ALL OF OUR BUSINESSES BOTH THE
PRIVATE AND OUR SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY. DESPITE THE
HARDSHIPS WE ARE MERGED AS A
COMMUNITY LEADER OFFER SAFE
HAVEN DURING THESE EVENTS THESE
EVENTS SUCH AS SHELTERING.
ROSSO OFFERING DIFFERENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN COORDINATION
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN OUR LOCAL WILL YES OPTIONS.
THE NEW CALL BACK AND WE TALK
ABOUT TODAY. IS MADE TO ENHANCE
THE NEXT TWENTY FIVE YEARS FOR
OUR TRIBAL ECONOMY AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOCAL
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES. IT
ALSO PROVIDES US AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTINUE TO GROW IN THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
COMMUNITY OPPORTUNITIES THAT
THE MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA PLANS
TO OFFER OVER THE NEXT TWO
DECADES. WHAT THE INFORMATION
THAT WAS PROVIDED EARLIER- BY
NATHAN. WHAT WILL COVER. WHAT
IT IS AT THE GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN
THE TRIBAL NEGOTIATOR INTERNAL
WORK OR SUPPORT OF THE
STREAMERS. WE HOPE THAT AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THIS INFORMATIONAL
PROCESS IF THINGS ARE MOVING
FORWARD IN THIS IS RATIFIED- AS
A COMPLETE COMPACT FOR THE
LITTLE TEMPERATURE. THE SMOKE
ONCE AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO TESTIFY
THAT TO GIVE YOU THE
INFORMATION AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT MAY NEED THE-
MAY BE ASKED. BUT WE ALSO WANT
TO THINK AGAIN RUDY SALAS
REMOVE THIS REPORT ON AB NINE
FIVE SEVEN. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY WHO HELPED US GET TO
THIS POINT. NORTH THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
COMING O THE TABLE.
NEGOTIATING IN GOOD FAITH THE
HELP WAS COMPLETE THIS COMPACT.
WITHOUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN SIMON AND
WHEN WE GET TO A QUESTION AND
ANSWER PERIOD WILL WILL WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO CALL YOU BACK
UPS OF. OPINION THANK YOU. US
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR- NEXT
SPEAKERS MARIO YOUR DATE HE DID
HE DID A VIDEO OF WESTERN
REGIONAL POLITICAL DIRECTOR
UNITER. THE INTERNATIONAL UNION
AFL-CIO I HOPE I DIDN'T GET
YOUR NAME- TOO MUCH MARIO. I
DON'T ALL CHAIRMAN TREASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR GOOD
MORNING AND GOOD MORNING TO THE
COMMITTEE- AND MEMBERS AND GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN SIMON- AND
MISTER BUCKLEY OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AGAIN MARIO
YOU DIDIA OTHER WESTERN
POLITICAL DIRECTOR WITH UNITE
HERE ARE WHERE THE HOSPITALITY
WORKERS UNION IN NORTH AMERICA.
WITH THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS WHO ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
PEOPLE OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS AND
WOMEN. AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE ARE EXTRAORDINARILY PROUD
THAT SEVEN THOUSAND OF US WORK
AT NINE TRIBAL CASINOS ACROSS
THE STATE- WHERE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS ENSURE
DIGNITY RESPECT FAIR WAGES AND
BENEFITS. THE UNION HAS NOT
OPPOSED A CONTACT IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN FOURTEEN YEARS
WE HAVE NOT DONE SO BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCES THAT ARE
INCORPORATED INTO COMPACTS IN
THAT TIME THAT PROTECTED
WORKERS ABILITY TO FREELY
ASSOCIATE. AND TO ORGANIZE A
UNION IF THEY SO CHOOSE. AND WE
DO NOT STAND BEFORE YOU THIS
MORNING IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA COMPACT.
INSTEAD WE WANT TO NOTE FOR THE
RECORD ARE SIGNIFICANT CONCERN
ABOUT THE STATUS OF TRIBAL
CASINO WORKER RIGHTS IN
CALIFORNIA UNDER VARIOUS TRIBAL
LABOR RELATIONS ORDINANCES. FOR
THREE REASONS- WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT LACK OF ENFORCEMENT BY
THE STATE IN LIGHT OF ONGOING
LITIGATION ABOUT TRIED TO IN
THE STATE ARGUING AGAINST THE
VALIDITY OF THE T. L. R. O. AS
A SUBJECT OF CONTACTING GO SHE
ASIANS. AND FINALLY ABOUT
ATTEMPTS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
DISTRICT NATIONAL LABOR
RELATIONS ACT FROM APPLICATION.
A TRIBAL CASINOS WE RECOGNIZE
AND AFFIRM. THE RIGHT OF TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY. WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
INDUSTRIAL PATTERNS IN FROM THE
RIGHT OF WORKERS TO FREELY
ASSOCIATE ARGONAUTS. ARE
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL GAMING IS A
NINE BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY
FOUR WORKERS DESERVE DIGNITY
AND RESPECT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS PEOPLE
AND BUCKLEY. IT'S ALL. THANK
YOU MARIA SO NOW WE'LL MOVE TO
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF ANY OF OUR PARTICIPANTS.
SEEING THAT I JUST HAVE ONE
FOR. OF THE ADMINISTRATION-
MISTER MOBILITY- CAN YOU OF
GIVES A QUICK OVERVIEW RECENT
DEVELOPMENTS RELATING TO THE
TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUND. I'LL
GIVE YOU A VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW
AND ALFONSE SAY- TRAVEL ADVISOR
CHRISTINE ASKED NIGHTER WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WOULD. BE
ULTIMATELY BETTER POSITION TO
FIGHT TO GET A FULL REPORT
PICTURES YOU CAN BE HAPPY TO DO
SO I THINK- EXCEPT FOR SOME
PLANS DURING KOBE BEING UPSET I
THINK OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE
ALREADY DONE SO BUT SHE'LL BE
AVAILABLE FOR THAT AFTERWARDS
TO. THE COMMITTEE WOULD PREFER.
I'M JUST A VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW
THE TNC AFTER AUTHORIZES THE
TRACK OUR TRIBAL NATIONS GRANT
FINE AUTHORIZES TRANSFER OF
EXCESS FUNDS. FROM THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND FOR GRANTS
TO LIMITED AND NON GAMING
TRIBES RELATED TO TRIBAL SELF
GOVERNANCE SELF DETERMINE
COMMUNITIES AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. MOST RECENTLY
THERE IS TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TRANSFERRED FROM THE
ARTIST YOU HAVE TO THE TNC-
ENTITY THAT TRIBAL NATIONS
GRANT PANEL HAS AWARDED OVER
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
TRIBES. THAT INCLUDES FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
APPROVED- FOR CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY GRANTS TO SIXTY TWO
DIFFERENT TRIBES. THERE ARE ALL
JUST NOTE THAT FOR THAT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
INTERESTED THERE IS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND REPORTS THAT
ARE NOW AVAILABLE ON ONE OF THE
TEAM'S YEP WEBSITE THAT'S TNG.
ERA DOT CA DOT GOV. PERFECT
THANK YOU SO MUCH JUST OTHER
FOR UP. I WOULDN'T THE CONTACTS
ARE. WHAT IS THE PROCESS FOR
CONSULTING WITH THE RESPECTIVE
CITIES OR COUNTIES- IN THEIR
INVOLVEMENT. GOOD QUESTION
GENERALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH THE TRIES
TO NEGOTIATE SPECIFIC IMPACTS
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON FOR CITIES OR
COUNTIES TO RAISE CONCERNS OR
PAST ISSUES THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IS AWARE OF AND TRIES TO
WORK THROUGH TO YOUR DRESS- BUT
IN GENERAL THE CONTACTS ARE
NEGOTIATED DIRECTLY BETWEEN THE
TRIBE AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
ON A GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
STATE TO TRAVEL LEVEL. THANK
YOU. AND WHAT I'M HOPING AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO IS A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS WHEN WE
LOOK AT. THE MAKING V. AS WE
HAVE THE CONTACTS WERE LOOKING
AT THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER.
AND RECOGNIZE AS THE- NOT ONLY
IS A SOVEREIGN NATION ARE GOING
ON A GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY BUT
ALSO A PARTNER IN A REGION TO
BE ABLE TO HELP THEM FLOURISH
AS A CALIFORNIA BUSINESS. SO
JUST LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
CONTINUANCE GOING FORWARD-
THANK YOU MISTER VULGARLY WE'RE
GONNA GO ON TO A- PUBLIC
COMMENT. A MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE- IN
INTERESTED IN COMMENTING. ON
THIS COMPACT. THE THIRD NEW ANY
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN CUBA WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ON THIS
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. A PART ME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WHILE WE PROVIDE THEIR LINE
NUMBER.
MODERATOR WE HAVE A
TECHNOLOGY ALL THESE. NO SIR WE
ARE JUST PROVIDING THE LINE
NEVER- WE ARE READY TO OPEN UP
LINE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS SUSAN JENSEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONS INDIAN
GAMING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE MODERATE. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH. SO THOSE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THAT'S TRUE WHAT USED TO THE.
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM OR THE
REMOTE STATION THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OR INFORMATIONAL FOR
THE COMMITTEE ON THE CONTACT.
THE FIRM CISCO ROAD RUN THREE
SUPPORT OF NONPROFIT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH CHARM. SO THAT
CONCLUDES OUR INFORMATIONAL
COMPONENT ON THE GAMING COMPACT
BETWEEN SHIP CALIFORNIA
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA OPPONENT
INDIANS AND I THINK THANK YOU
FOR ALL THE PARTICIPANTS. WE'RE
GONNA GO AND MOVE ON TO OUR
SECOND- CONTACT AND THAT IS
THE- TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACT BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AT SANTA ROSA INDIAN
COMMUNITY OF THE SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIA. HI WE'RE GOING TO
FIRST START OFF WITH- MISTER
WILL KILL YOU AGAIN- MISTER
WILLIE PLEASE. YOU HAVE A. FOR
THANK YOU CHAIR OUR SERVER THIS
I'M GOING TO BEGIN I'LL JUST GO
OVER THE TERMS WITH THE VICTIM
SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA AND ALL
FOCUS ON THE ECONOMIC TERMS TO
START WITH. THAT SANTA ROSA
RETREAT CURRENTLY OPERATES
APPROXIMATELY TWO THOUSAND
GAMING DEVICES THAT IT'S TACKY
PALACE CASINO RESORT IN KINGS
COUNTY UNDER THE NEW CONTACTS
SANTA ROSA RANCH REAL BE ABLE
TO OPERATE UP TO THREE THOUSAND
TOTAL GAMING DEVICES ACROSS
THREE FACILITIES. WHEN IT'S
OPERATING OVER TWELVE HUNDRED
GAMING DEVICES THE TRIED
COMMITTED TO CONTRIBUTING FOR
NICOLE- PERCENT OF GROSS GAMING
REVENUE WILL IMMEDIATELY IT
INTERRUPT THE WE CAN HARDLY.
HEAR YOU CAN YOU TURN YOUR
VOLUME UP FORCE PLEASE- IS
THERE ANY HERE. YES IT IS. OKAY
I'LL TRY AND JUST BE A LITTLE
LOUDER THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH WHAT I WAS SAYING WHEN THE
CENTER OF THE RANCHERIAS
CASINOS OPERATING OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED GAMING DEVICES THE
TRIBAL CONTRIBUTE FOR A QUARTER
PERCENT OF ITS GROSS GAMING
REVENUE. OVER THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DEVICES TO THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST BAND OR ARTIST
YEAH. RST F. AS THE PRIMARY
SOURCE OF REVENUE FOR A ONE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLAR
DISBURSEMENT. EACH THE BENEFIT
AND NON GAMING TRIBES. ACCESS
ARE STF FUNDS CAN BE GRANTED TO
TRIED STATEWIDE THROUGH THE
TRIBAL NATIONS GRANT FIND. IN
SUPPORTOF ACRES GOALS OF
TRIBAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
SELF SUFFICIENCY AND STRONG
KIND OF GOVERNMENTS. SANTA ROSA
MAINSTREET IS ABLE TO CREDIT
AGAINST ITS RST HALF OBLIGATION
IT'S PAYMENTS TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS FOR THINGS LIKE
SERVICES RELATED TO FIRE.
MEDICAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
EDUCATION. ENTERTAINMENT
SUPPORTING HOUSING FOR ITS
ELDERS. AND FOR PEOPLE AND
FINANCIAL NEED. RELATED TO THE
HELL AND SAY ND LABOR PROTECT
SAN ROSA RANCH AND ASSEMBLY TO
MIDDLE TO RANCHERIA. PROHIBITS
THOSE UNDER TWENTY ONE FROM
GAINING OR PURCHASING TOBACCO
PRODUCTS. SANTA ROSA RANCHERIAS
CONTACTING CORPORATE STRIVE
ALONG REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE
MINIMUM STANDARDS IN ADDRESSING
PAGER DISPUTES TORTS AND
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION. THE
T. L. R. O. FOR SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIAS THAT SAME AS
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA AND OTHERS.
THE BINDING DISPUTE RESOLUTION
FOR COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
ISSUES YET THE UNION ACCEPTS
THE TLR. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY GOT RID OF THE%
DISTAL SPECIFIC PROVISIONS FOR
SANTA ROSA RANCH REMAINED AT
NUMBER OF ANIMAL FOR ANY
QUESTIONS RELATED TO IT. THANK
YOU SIR WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT SPEAKER. AND WE HAVE-
CHAIRMAN NEW CISCO SANTA ROSA
INDIAN COMMITTEE OF SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIA. AND HE'LL BE
TESTIFYING FROM THE- MICROPHONE
YES PLEASE. YOU DO NOT HAVE.
WELL THEY HAVE ALL SPEAKERS ARE
COMING UP TO AS LONG AS A
COMMITTEES NOT OF. ABOUT JUST
TRYING TO SEE ARTICLES. PLEASE
HAVE A SEAT SIR AND THANK YOU
FOR YOURS. RIVAS CHAIR MEMBERS-
MY NAME IS LEO CISCO THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE CENTER WAS A
RENTERIA TEST YOU HAVE TO TRY.
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB. NINE FIFTY SEVEN. TO
RATIFY AN AMENDMENT OF THE TO
THE CENTER OF THE RANCHERIA
TAPIOCA TRIBE. GAMING COMPACT
WITH THE SENATE WITH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. FIRST LIKE TO
THINK IT'S A WOMEN SALAS FOR
SUPPORT OF A COMBAT. IN HIS WIN
TO SPONSOR RHETORIC BILL. ALL
WANT TO THANK HIM FOR DOWN TO
CENTER OF VENTURE. TO ME WITH
OUR TRUCK COUNCIL THANK THE-
AREA HIS COMMITMENT TO MY
PEOPLE. I ALSO LIKE TO THANK
CHAMBER FRAZIER. FOR MEETING
WITH US AND FOR ITS COMMITMENT
TO SUPPORTING OUR CONTACT.
SPEAKING. I ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE MANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE ASSEMBLY AS
WE MOVE THIS IN THIS COMPACT
FOR TO RATIFICATION. JUST TO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BACKGROUND-
CENTER WAS RENTERIA IS. LOCATED
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
ABOUT FIVE MILES SOUTH OF THE
MORE. FOR THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW
WHERE THE MORE IS ABOUT HALFWAY
CURRENTLY HAVE OVER ONE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED TRIBAL
MEMBERS. NUMBER NINETEEN NINETY
NINE STATE TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACT. HE TRIBE CURRENTLY
OPERATES THE ATTACH APOSTASY A
RESORT. AS MR VOGEL HE SAID
WITH- TWO THOUSAND GAMING
DEVICES. BUT WE COME FROM VERY
HUMBLE BEGINNINGS. OUR PEOPLE
USED TO LIVE AND BROKE DOWN
CARS CHICKEN COOPS AT HOMES
THAT AVAILABLE IN MULTIPLE
COUNTIES IN THEM. INSTEAD OF
GOING TO SCHOOL FAMILIES WORK
IN THE FIELDS TO PUT FOOD ON
THE TABLE. WATER HAD TO BE
HEATED OR HAVE A WARM BATH. IN
SOME OF THEM EVEN HAVE NO
RUNNING WATER. THE NOVEMBER
THIRD NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
CHANGED OUR LIVES FOREVER. OUR
GAME OF FACILITY GAVE US
OPPORTUNITIES OUR ANCESTORS
GOING DREAM OF. AND I AM PROUD
TO SAY THAT GAMING HAS ALLOWED
US TO PROVIDE HOUSING FOR
PEOPLE. OUR ELDERS ARE LIVING
LONGER BECAUSE WE CAN PROVIDE
THEM HEALTH INSURANCE SO THEY
CAN RECEIVE THE PROPER HEALTH
CARE THAT THEY NEED. WE HAVE A
SPECIAL WE HAVE A SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT TO ASSIST
OUR COMMUNITY. I'LL TELL
MEMBERS ARE NOW BECOMING
ENTREPRENEURS. ARE YOU THERE
GRADUATING AND GOING TO COLLEGE
AND THE TRIBE PAYS FOR. WE NOW
PLOY OVER A THOUSAND PEOPLE AN
PROVIDE THEM WITH GOOD PAYING
JOBS AND GREAT BENEFITS. WHEN
THE TRY FLOURISHES EVERYONE
AROUND BENEFITS. SENATE WAS
ORIGINALLY HAS ALSO FOUGHT FOR
THE GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY. AS WELL AS OUR LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH A
DETERMINATION TO INCREASE THE
STANDARD OF LIVING AND QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR TRIBAL MEMBERS AND
KINGS COUNTY COMMITTEE OF THE
WHOLE. OUR TRIBE HAS
ESTABLISHED SEVERAL ECONOMIC. A
DEVELOPMENTAL PRIZES ATTACH A
**** IN RESORTS COVERED
ENTERTAINMENT CENTER. OKAY GAS
STATION SEQUOIA AND IN A
RECENTLY PURCHASED THIRTY FARMS.
THE PURPOSE OF THESE
ENTERPRISES IT'S A REVIVED
APARTMENT OPPORTUNITIES PROVIDE
ENTERTAINMENT FLOODING NEEDS
AND ASSIST IN GETTING SELF
SUFFICIENCY NOT ONLY FOR THIRTY
OKAY PEOPLE. BEFORE THE ENTIRE
KINGS COUNTY COMMUNITY.
EVERYONE WILL BENEFIT FROM THE
TREMENDOUS RELATIONSHIP THAT
THAT HAS BEEN BUILT BY OUR
TRIBE AND KINGS COUNTY. WE
EXPECT THAT THIS RELATIONSHIP
WILL CONTINUE TO FLOURISH IN
MANY YEARS TO COME. EARLIER
THIS YEAR OUR TRIBE AND KINGS
COUNTY SIGNED AN
INTERGOVERNMENTAL AGREEMENT. TO
ALLOW CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW
FIRE STATION. PUBLIC SAFETY AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT SUPPORT
FOR KINGS COUNTY. AS WELL THE
EXPENSE OF THE TOUCH ABOUT THE
SCENE RESORT. THE OUR
GOVERNMENT GRANT WILL ALLOW
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN OUR TRIBE
KINGS COUNTY TO GROW OVER THE
TERM OF THE AGREEMENT.
FOREGOING A STRONG PARTNERSHIP
LONG INTO THE FUTURE. THE TOUCH
OPPOSE CASINO RESORT IS DOING
ITS ABSOLUTE BEST AND CONTINUE
TO GET THROUGH THE COVER
PANDEMIC. WITH THE INCREASE
PROTECTIONS BY IMPLEMENTING
VARIOUS POLICIES. INCLUDING A
SAFETY AMBASSADOR PROGRAM. FOR
OVER NINETEEN RE OPENING IN
PHASES. AND ALL BOARDED TRAIN
TO ENSURE THE ALL NEW EMPLOYEES
ARE WELL TRAINED WITH REGARD TO
COVERT SAFETY REQUIREMENTS. OUR
TOPIC WAS NEGOTIATE OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS. AND WE
FINALLY CAME TO AGREEMENT WITH
THE GOVERNOR BACK IN APRIL. AT
NO TIME DURING NEGOTIATIONS DO
WE HEAR ANY NEW LANGUAGE OR
CHANGES NEEDED IN OUR TRIBAL
LABOR RELATIONS ORDINANCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS CONFIRMED
TO US THAT OUR TLR IS
SUFFICIENT AND WAS PROPERLY
NEGOTIATED. THE NEW CONTACT
ENHANCES THE REGULATION OF
CLASS THREE GAMING. VENTURES
THAT IS A FAIR AND HONEST
OPERATION. IN A WAY THAT
PROTECTS THE INTERESTS OF THE
TRIBE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IT CITIZENS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. UNDER THE NEW
COMPACT THE TRIBE IS AUTHORIZED
OPERATE UP TO THREE THOUSAND
GAMING DEVICES ON LANDOWNERS
HELD IN TRUST FOR THE TRIBE.
THE TRIBE IS REQUIRED TO
COVERAGE PROVIDED SHARE OF THE
COSTS INCURRED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN PERFORMANCE OF
ITS REGULATORY DUTIES. INTO THE
INDIAN GAMING SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND. THE
LICENSING REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION.
PATRON PROTECTION LABOR PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND SAFETY PROVISIONS
ARE SIMILAR TO OTHER RECENT
TOPICS. WITH MANY NEW REVISIONS
WITH DESERVE MAJOR REVISIONS
WHICH GREATLY IMPROVE THE
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE SENATE
TECHNIQUE TOUCHY OKAY TRIBE AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
PLEASED THAT GOVERNOR NEWSOM
AND HIS TRAVEL NEGOTIATORS AND
THE MARK IN THE ASSEMBLY. ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS FRAMEWORK
AND ASK FOR SUPPORT AS WELL AND
RATIFYING A CONTACT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. OUR TOPIC IS
SUPPORTED BY THE KINGS COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. KINGS
COUNTY SHERIFF DAVID ROBINSON.
KINGS COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT.
THE CITY OF THE MORE.
CALIFORNIA NATIONS INDIAN
GAMING ASSOCIATION AND OUR AREA
CONGRESSMAN THEIR LAW THEY ARE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AS FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB NINE FIFTY
SEVEN THANK YOU WELL DONE MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU- WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER
MARIO YOU. OF THE FLOOR. THE
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER GOOD MORNING
ONCE MORE TO YOU AND MEMBERS
AND GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
CISCO- HERE PLAT REMAINS
NEUTRAL ON THIS CONTACT- FOR
THAT THREE REASONS STATED
EARLIER REGARDING OUR CONCERNS
ABOUT ENFORCEMENT OF TRIBAL
LABOR RELATIONS ORDINANCES
WRITTEN LARGE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE CHAIRMAN
OF FROM THE COMMITTEE. MICELLES
WHO OUR BILL YOU WANT TO MAKE
ANY COLOR AT ALL. NO QUESTION
BUT A COMMENT. RIGHT THAT THEY
DETERMINE CISCO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE OBVIOUSLY BETWEEN
BOTH OF THESE COMPACTS THAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY-
NAPLES TRIBE AND IT'S NOT ONLY-
BE SELF SUFFICIENT BUT ACTUALLY
WHAT I APPRECIATE MOST IS THE
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS. AND
WORKING TOGETHER WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN THE COMMUNITIES
IN THE ORGANIZATION TO SAY WE
ARE PART OF THIS COMMUNITY WE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE A PART OF
THIS COMMUNITY AND THAT
COMMITMENT. LIVING FORWARD I
THINK IS WHAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
AND APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING OUT OF THE COMMUNITY. SO
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOUNG WOMEN
JUST BACK UP HERE AND GO TO-
MISTER VOCALLY CLUB ABOUT A
QUESTION. AND CAN YOU EXPLAIN
HOW THE LABOR PROVISIONS ARE
SIMILAR TO THOSE IN THE RECENT
COMPAQ'S. THANK YOU THREE HAPPY
TO COVER THAT SOME OF THE
RECENT CONTACTS SIMILAR TO
MIDDLETOWN IN SANTA ROSA
INCLUDED TRAVEL LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCE LANGUAGE SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO WHETHER A- WHAT
OCCURS IF A LABOR ORGANIZATION
OFFERS TO ACCEPT. THE TRIBAL
RELATIONS ORDINANCE. THAT LABOR
ORGANIZATION DOES OFFER TO
ACCEPT THAN THE TRIBE AGREES
THROUGH ITS ORDINANCE TO ACCEPT
THAT OFFER. FORMING A BILATERAL
CONTRACT. DISPUTES ARE TO BE
RESOLVED THROUGH BINDING
DISPUTE RESOLUTION THIS
INCLUDES COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
DISPUTES AND OTHER
DISAGREEMENTS UNDER THE TLR AT.
LARA SPECIFICALLY INCLUDE TO
TRY MAN WAIVER O SOVEREIGN
IMMUNITY TO ALLOW OUR TO
PROCEED AND BUYING THE TRIBE IN
THE CASE OF IT FIND JUDGMENT.
RT REVIEW TO ARBITRATE OR WITH
IN ORDER TO AWARD THEN THE
OTHER PARTY CAN SEEKING. IN
COURT. PERFECT THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GONNA GO ON TO NOW A
PUBLIC COMMENT MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANYBODY IN THE IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS COMPACT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THAT ZERO. THE COMMAND AGAIN
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GERMAN
THEN. REMEMBERS STEVEN JOHNSON
CALIFORNIA NATIONS INDIAN
GAMING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT
MODERATOR IF THERE IS ANYTHING.
AND WE ALSO HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM LINE THIRTY ONE.
HELLO THANK YOU ARE CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS FRANK MOLINA ON
BEHALF OF THE SEMINAL BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL
MOVE OVER INTO IN PERSON
COMMENTS IN THE CHAMBERS RIGHT
NOW ANYBODY IN THE CHAMBERS I
HAVE COMMENTS FOR- THIS COMPACT.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME AND THE
REPRESENTING HI MICHELLE
OPINION I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA AND SANTA
ROSA RANCHERIA AND CHAIRMAN
SIMON WANTED TO. WEIGH IN AND
EXPRESS HIS TRIBE SUPPORT FOR
THE CENTER IS A RANCHERIA
TOUCHY TRIBE AND I'M NOT SURE
IF WE'RE ABLE TO DO THAT.
ONLINE BUT- HE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS HIS SUPPORT. OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. I WILL MOVE OVER
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION A
DOORS ON OUR STEPS THE COMPANY
BUDDY. IN THE QUEUE ON THAT.
SEEING NONE- GERMAN THANK YOU
FOR COMING IN PRSON- IN THESE
THESE DAYS AGO IS REALLY
IMPRESSIVE AND YOU SEE THE
AMOUNT OF MEMBERS ON A FRIDAY
AFTERNOON HERE- THIS IS UNUSUAL
AND THIS WAS THE SHOWS THE
RESPECT YOU DESERVE BEING HERE
AND- ALL THE OTHER CHAIRMAN.
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE. THAT WILL CONCLUDE
THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
THE- TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACT PRINCE TO CALIFORNIANS
SANTA ROSA INDIAN COMMITTEE OF
THE SENATE RULES A RANCHER RIO-
WE WILL MOVE ON TO NUMBER
THREE- AND- THIS WILL BE THE
TRAVELGATE- STATE GAMING
COMPACT BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND PICAYUNE-
REGISTRY OF THE CHURCH AS HE-
INDIAN SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK
TO MR O'KELLY- SO FOR YEARS.
THANK YOU CHAIR THE ALL TAKE
THIS ONE THE SAME WAY I DID
PERCENT AROSE I'LL JUST POINT
OUT THAT VISIONS THAT ARE
SPECIFIC TO PICK UNION
RANCHERIA AND I'LL START WITH
THEIR ECONOMIC TERMS. THAT MAKE
YOU RANCHERIAS CHECK CHANCY
GOLD RESORT CASINOS LOCATED IN
MADERA COUNTY AND INCLUDES
NEARLY TWO THOUSAND GAMING
DEVICES THE TRIBE UNDER THIS
NEW CONTACT IN OPERATE UP TO
THREE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
GAMING DEVICES IT AGREED TO
CONTRIBUTE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO
THE SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION FIND
IN ADDITION TO ITS PRO RATA
SHARE WHEN IT'S OPERATING OVER
THREE THOUSAND GAMING DEVICES.
THIS FLAT FEE HELP SUPPORT
TWENTY EIGHTEEN LEGISLATION
THAT ALLOWS FOR THE ELIMINATION
OR REDUCTION OF STF FOR AROUND
OF PAYMENTS BY LIMITED GAMING
TRIBES WHEN THERE ARE
SUFFICIENT. FUNDS IN THE STF.
THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING ALL
COMMITTED TO OUR OF PAYMENTS
RANGE FROM 2% IN THAT WHEN
OFFER OUT THREE FIFTY. BY AT
FIVE AND A HALF IN THAT WIN
OVER THREE THOUSAND DEVICES. I
TRIED ARE STF BONTA ABUSE IN A
MATTER ITS COMMITMENT TO
ONGOING SUPPORT OF LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND FIRE SERVICES.
THERE AND- YOU WITH MADERA
COUNTY. EXISTING CONTACTS
GENERALLY ALLOW AMENDMENT IF
THERE IS A MATERIAL AND ADVERSE
AFFECT THAT MADE MY TRIBAL
OBLIGATIONS ON DULY ONEROUS. IN
THE CASE OF PICAYUNE RANCHERIA
IF THE TRI DEMONSTRATES THAT
IT'S NOT NGUYEN HAS DECREASED
BY FIFTEEN PERCENT. DUE TO THE
OPENING OR EXPANSION OF ANOTHER
TRIBAL GAMING FACILITY WITHIN
SIXTY MILES THEN THE STATE
AGREED TO NEGOTIATE AMENDMENTS
TO THE COMPACT. THANK YOUNG
RENTERIA'S COMPACT LARGE
INCLUDES SIMILAR HEALTH SAFETY
AND LABOR PROTECTIONS I
DISCUSSED FOR MIDDLETOWN IN FOR
SANTA ROSA RANCHERIAS. THE
TRIED TO CONTACT WOULD ALLOW
THOSE OVER AGE EIGHTEEN TO GAME
AND REQUIRES ANYONE PURCHASING
TO BUY TOBACCO PRODUCTS TO MEET
THE MINIMUM AGE UNDER STATE LAW.
BEGINS RENTERIA COMPACT AS FOR
THE OTHER TWO CONTACTS
INCORPORATES TRIBAL TOWARD
AGING DISPUTE EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION ORDINANCES.
WHICH AFFECTS YELLOW VARIES
FROM THAT OF MIDDLETOWN IN
SANTA ROSA RANCHERIAS WITH
MODIFIED LANGUAGE THAT'S
BENEFICIAL TO THE TRIGRAMS OF
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS. THE T. L.
R. O. THERE'S A FOR PICKING.
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
CONSEQUENCES IF THE TRIBE OR
THE LABOR ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE
DURING THE ORGANIZING PERIOD.
THE TRIBE MAY BE REQUIRED TO
AUTOMATICALLY RECOGNIZE THE
LABOR ORGANIZATION WHILE THE
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS ELECTION
COULD BE DELAYED. IN
RECOGNITION OF SOME LIMITED
HAVE SOME LOOK MEDICATION
RELATED TO THE TLR ADAM THE
TRAVESTY ARE OF INCLUDES
PROVISIONS SPECIFYING. THAT
PARTY IS NOT REQUIRED TO
EXHAUST TRAVEL COURT REMEDIES
TO COMPEL AND FORCE AN
ARBITRATION AWARD BEFORE GOING
TO FEDERAL COURT. AND A PARTY
CHALLENGING ARBITRATION AWARD
OR THE DUTY TO ARBITRATE IS
LIABLE FOR THE OTHER PARTY'S
ATTORNEYS HE'S- ALSO CLARIFIES
THAT THE TRIBAL LABOR PANEL IS
NOT SPECIFIC TO ONE DRIVE AT
ALL TIMES. FINALLY HAVE A LABOR
ORGANIZATION ATTEMPTS ORGANIZED
UNDER THE NATIONAL LABOR
RELATIONS ACT THEN IT'S BARRED
FROM ORGANIZING UNDER THE D. L.
R. O. FOR ONE YEAR. AS AS
ENVIRONMENT PROTECTION SIMILAR
TO THOSE FOR MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA. BIKINI GRANT THREE
ALLOWS THE TRIED TO USE AN
ALTERNATIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW PROCESS IF THE TRIBE
WILL BE OPERATING LESS THAN
THREE INTERN FORTY NINE GAMES.
IN ADDITION PICKING RANCHERIA
ITS COMPACT INCLUDES LANGUAGE
REGARDING THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL
OF DEFERENCE AND REVIEW FOR A
TRAVEL DECISION. THE LANGUAGE
IS ANALOGOUS TO THAT USED IN
THE CONTEXT OF A LEAD AGENCY
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT.
FINALLY THE PECAN RANCHERIAS
CONTACTUS THE RESOLUTION
PROCESS LARGELY MIMICS THAT FOR
MIDDLETOWN SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA
BUT PROVIDES FOR A SIXTY DAY
PERIOD RATHER THAN THIRTY DAYS.
SECURITY BREACH AFTER FINAL
JUDGMENT. THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AGAIN TO GO OVER
THESE TERMS SPECIFIC TO PICK
UNION ANDREA AND I'M A- WILL
REMAIN AVAILABLE FOR ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS AS WELL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WILL MOVE TO OUR NEXT
SPEAKER. WHICH IS THE CHAIR
CLAUDIA GONZALEZ OF PICAYUNE
RETREAT RANCHERIA OF THE TWO
CHANCY INDIANS WELCOME CHAIR.
CHAIRING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CLAUDIA GONZALEZ I AM
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE US REACTOR
TNC INDIANS I THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW FOR GREEN AUTHOR
SB THREE OH TWO. ALSO I THINK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THE TIME TO
PROVIDE SOME BRIEF REMARKS
TODAY IT'S COMING. THIS CONTACT
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY
REPRESENTS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF WORK BY BOTH THREE AND THE
TRIBAL COUNCIL. YOU WANT TO
THINK GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND HIS
CHILD SHARE AND MARK FOR
DEVELOPING THE TIME DURING
THESE DIFFICULT. A TIME OF
COULD NOT CANTON AT PRESIDENT
TO COMMUNICANTS. ON THE NUMBER
ISSUES PURCHASED. AT THE
MUTUALLY BENEFIT. IN OUR
AGREEMENT. AB HAS BEEN A KEY TO
ACTING DEVELOPMENT YOU FOR
SEVERAL DECADES. WE ARE OUT OF
OUR CHANCE WILL RESIGN AND YOU
WHICH IS BEEN IN OPERATION
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND THREE
AND IS LOCATED IN COARSE GOLD.
MADERA COUNTY. OUR GOAL IS
REALLY TO THIS COMPACT IS TO
PROVIDE CERTAINTY FOR THE
FUTURE OF OUR TRIBE. IS
IMPORTANT THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT AS WE CONTINUE TO
STRIVE TO PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE COMMUNITY.
MAINTAIN CONTINUOUS SAFE
OPERATIONS IN ECONOMIC
ENTERPRISES. AND BECOME CRUCIAL
TO OUR MEMBERS. THIS ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDED TO OUR
TRIBE AND SURROUNDING COMMUNITY
HAS BECOME EVEN MORE VITAL AS
WE FACE THE CHALLENGES INDUCED
BY THIS CLUB IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. DURING THE PANDEMIC
WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED AN ENHANCED
PUBLIC SAFETY STANDARDS FOR THE
CITY OF OUR PATRONS AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. ARE WE CURRENTLY
EMPLOYED OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS A RESORT AND
CASINO OPERATIONS. I KNOW ONE
OF THE LARGEST EMPLOYERS IN THE
REGION. OUR RESORT CASINO HAS
DONE MORE THAN JUST PROVIDE
ECONOMIC ENGINE FOR OUR
MEMBERSHIP IN SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY. WE HAVE ALSO SERVED
AS A SAFE HAVEN DURING THE
NATURAL DISASTERS DURING THE
CREEK FIRE. WE WERE ABLE TO
HOUSE NUMEROUS FAMILIES SEEKING
SHELTER AND WORKING CLOSELY
WITH FEDERAL AND STATE
OFFICIALS TO ENSURE THE MEMBERS
HAVE ACCESS TO BASIC
NECESSITIES. THIS NEW COMPACT
WILL ALLOW US TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL HEALTH
EDUCATION. ECONOMIC PROGRAMS
AND OTHER SERVICES TO OUR
TRIBAL COMMUNITY. AT THE SAME
TIME THE CONTACT PROVIDES
BENEFITS TO THE STATE
PROTECTING OUR EMPLOYEES. TO
OUR CUSTOMERS AND THE LARGER
MADERA COUNTY COMMUNITY OVER
THE YEARS THE EVEN HAS ENJOYED
A STRONG RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
LOCAL LEADERS AND WE GET HAD A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH THE PROJECT ACCOUNT. THREE
THOUSAND ONE. IN THE TRIED HAVE
A LONG STANDING AGREEMENT ON
ISSUES RELATED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT SERVICES. FIRE
PROTECTION TRAFFIC AND ROAD
MAINTENANCE WATER AND SEWER
SUPPORT. AS WELL AS JOBS AND
SOCIAL SERVICES. IT TRIBE HAS
AGREED TO INCREASE THE LEVEL OF
FINANCIAL SUPPORT PROVIDED TO
THE COUNTY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND FIRE PROTECTION SERVICES.
FINALLY WE WANT TO PUBLICLY
STATE THAT WE SUPPORT AND HONOR
RTL OR THAT WE HAVE ENJOYED A
POSITIVE WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH LABOR FOR ALMOST TWO
DECADES IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR THANK YOU AND THE NEXT
YEAR. EXECUTED A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT AND THIS
HAS REMAINED IN PLACE EVER
SINCE ONCE AGAIN I APPRECIATE
BEING ABLE TO BRIEF YOU ON OUR
CONTACTS AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE LEGISLATOR BATTER I
THINK IT'S CONTACTED STATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU JUERGENS ALSO MOVE ON
TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER WHICH IS-
MARIO YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS YOU HAVE THE FLOOR. DO
CHAIR MEN FRAZIER MEMBERS ONCE
MORE AND- GOOD MORNING MATT
GOOD MORNING J. CHAIRWOMAN
GONZALEZ THIS MORNING UNITE
HERE WISHES TO ENTHUSIASTICALLY
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE NEW
CONTACT BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE PICU
RENTERIA CHUCK CHANCY INDIANS
OF CALIFORNIA. THE CHECK
CHELSEA GOLD RESORT AND CASINO-
MAINTAINS A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT WITH UNITE
HERE LOCAL NINETEEN AS
CHAIRWOMAN GONZALEZ JUST SPOKE
TO- FOR ITS SIX HUNDRED WORKERS
AND THAT CBA GUARANTEES FAIR
WAGES AND BENEFITS AFFORDABLE
HEALTH VISION AND DENTAL
INSURANCE AND DIGNITY AND
RESPECT. YOU NINETY HERE DEEPLY
VALUES ARE POSITIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHUCK CHANCY
GOLD RESORT CASINO AND THE
QUALITY OF THE JOBS THERE WE
THANK THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR
NEGOTIATING THIS CONTACT AND WE
ASK THE LEGISLATURE TO PLEASE
APPROVE IT. WITHOUT DELAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SO WE'LL MOVE TO COMMENTS ARE.
OF THE PANEL FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE OF WILL MOVE ON TO
A PUBLIC COMMENT MODERATORS
THERE ANY COLORS IN THE QUEUE.
I FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
COMPACT. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
TECH COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO AND
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN SUSAN JENSEN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NATIONS
INDIAN GAMING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
WE HAVE A COUPLE MORE- PEOPLE
QUEUING UP FOR COMMENT ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH LINE NUMBERS. HI THIS
IS MAGGIE YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT. YES PLEASE PROCEED.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
COMMENT. MODERATOR DID WE LOSE
THAT COMMENT. YES IT LOOKS LIKE
WE HAVE LOST THAT PERSON WE DO
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE TWENTY
NINE HOWEVER PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON HERE MEMBERS
CONSULTED OFTEN WHICH I ENTER
INTO SOUTHERN LAYING ON BEHALF
OF MADERA COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF
THE TRAVEL GAMING COMPACT THE
COUNTY POSITION IS AFFECTING A
LOT OF SUPPORT FOR THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LINE FIVE. PLEASE PROCEED.
BY CHAIRMAN FRAZIER AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS CHRIS
ONCE FROM WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
TRIBAL BUSINESS FINANCE WE ARE
STRONGLY SUPPORTING- PECANS
COMPACT AND- JR PRINTABLE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL MOVE ON TO ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE CHAMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN. FOR
OPPOSITION OR ANY KIND OF
COMMENTS ON THE COMPACT. ANY
MEMBERS AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION OUTDOORS ON OR STEP OF
THE CAPITAL. SEEING NONE. I
WILL GO AHEAD AND- I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT-
RECENTLY I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
AND THAT THE PLEASURE TO BE
ABLE TO GO DOWN DURING OUR
SUMMER BREAK AND- TOUR SOME OF
THE- GAMING GAMING FACILITIES
THANKS SAN DIEGO COUNTY. AND I
WAS VERY VERY IMPRESSED THAT
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT WERE.
BUT GIVEN EARNED IN AND MADE BY
THE OF NATIVE AMERICANS IN IN
THAT COUNTY- WHEN YOU LOOK AND
SEE WHERE THEIR LANDS WERE
CITED. AND- AND YOU KNOW IT WAS
I HAVE TO DESCRIBE IT IS MAKING
A SILK PURSE OUT OF A SOW'S
EAR- MAY MADE SOMETHING OUT OF
OUT OF A- DESPERATE SITUATION
AS TERMS I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT
WERE LIVING CONDITIONS WERE
BLEAK AND NOW HAVE UPLIFTED
THEIR- THEIR CULTURE AND THEIR
PEOPLE. OF AND THEY DID IT AT
THE RISK. PLEADED THEIR RISK
AND THEY DID IT THEIR WAY AND
THEY MADE SOMETHING OF
THEMSELVES AND I HAVE TO THANK
THEM FOR THE CONTRIBUTION
THEY'RE MAKING IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO I'M A
NATIVE AMERICAN MY TRIBE ISN'T
FROM CALIFORNIA- BUT I AM PROUD
TO SEE. THAT THE CULTURAL.
BEING UPHELD THE CULTURE BEING
APPEALED. HAS BEEN.
DEMONSTRATED AND WHEN I WAS
TOURING- THE PEOPLE IN THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY WERE THE
BENEFACTORS ALSO. OF THIS OF
THESE OPPORTUNITIES. AND SO ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I WANT TO
IMPRESS UPON US AS WITH AS A
BODY BUT ALSO AS A STATE IS TO
CONTINUE TO PARTNER. BECAUSE
WHEN THESE ENTITIES FOR SO DO
WE CONSIDER THIS RUNNING
COMMUNITIES. AND THE MORE
SUPPORT THATTHEY HAVE THE
BETTER OFF THEIR FOLKS WILL BE
AND ALSO THE PEOPLE THAT THEY
ALSO BRING INTO THE FOLD AND
HELP. AND THESE ARE THINGS THAT
ORDINARILY WOULD NOT HAVE
GOTTEN DONE. FOR THESE FOLKS
HAD THEY NOT TAKEN THIS RISK
AND MADE THIS HAPPEN. SO I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S-
STAFF AND INVOLVEMENT-
NEGOTIATED COMPACTS BUT MAKING
SURE THAT THE SUPPORT FOR THIS.
THIS POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA
IS ENTERING AND CONTINUING-
RECOGNIZING THE ILLS THAT WERE
AFFORDED IN THE PAST. MR RAMOS
HAS BEEN VERY. ADAMANT ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED NAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT WHO MIGHT PLAY WHICH IS
GOOD OUR- SO. MAKE SURE YOU
KNOW THAT WE ALWAYS UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS A CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ALSO. CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS THAT SUPPORTS PEOPLE
SUPPORTS LABOR. IN MANY
INSTANCES AND WANTS TO BE ABLE
TO BE A PRODUCTIVE. UNIT AND AN
ENTITY IN CALIFORNIA SORRY FOR
THAT ALL THE CHAIRS ALL THE
PEOPLE OF THE TRIBAL COUNCIL'S
ALL THE RESERVATIONS EITHER
THANK YOU APPLAUD YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'VE DONE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
AGAIN YOU MADE A SILK PURSE OUT
OF SOW'S EAR THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE ARE. ADJOURNED.